FDX crypto Cup in Miami prag won it in
Blitz tie breaks so let's see what
happens today will Magnus be out for
Revenge if Magnus wins in the rapid
portion he will win the Tour finals for
Rapid games to decide the match three
points for the winner if they are tied
later then it will be decided in tie
breaks two points for the winner and one
point for the loser and here we go here
we go Andy bank is going to be very
happy Magnus opening with the current
defense yet again I am extremely happy
my favorite opening on the board and I'm
a little bit worried because Magnus is
pausing there you go he hasn't shaken my
faith in the caracon and here comes the
light squared bishop and this is such a
trendy move right now just it's so
tricky as well and black normally hands
handles this H4 Push by actually copying
and once again the players are following
the fashion and now the light Square
Bishop comes out and offers a trade and
this is very very thematic he pushes the
e-pawn forward one square forward this
actually isn't the line that I recommend
or all play but it is still very good
lots of action are going to be on the
board pragma pragmatic prag
going for the most critical lines the
one thing I will say about magnus's
opening choice is the caracon it's a
great opening but his results there are
far inferior to his results in nearly
every other opening Magnus with one E5
with the Sicilian with the French scores
really well but in the karakan he's had
many defeats and often does find himself
in these really difficult positions I
think that's because Magnus he wants the
space advantage and here if anyone it's
white in the center of the board having
stepped forward quite far it's white
with that extra space so I'm slightly
worried in terms of chest style this
favors Prague Prague will get very
active play and Magnus already thinking
on this early stage a very well known
position as Ivanka mentioned and that's
a slightly worrying sign for magnus's
fans it is slightly worrying and I do
have to say that prank has played a
slightly unusual second move I mean it's
only very slightly unusual because
usually the dark squared Bishop comes
out and attacks the queen but uh I don't
see any reason why Prague sorry sir
Magnus can't go into my favorite
variation which is actually to give a
check to the white king put the queen on
A5 yep and that does preface a even
deeper idea first it's a check you hit
the white king and no matter how white
blocks for example with a knight with a
pawn Black's idea quite often is to
slide back and try to trade off these
Queens black remember is a bit cramped
due to the structure in the middle White
having more space here these pawns
against these slightly inferior black
Pawns in the middle so swapping pieces
when you are a bit cramped is normally a
big benefit here I'm expecting Prague if
this does happen to block most likely he
would push a pawn forward he wouldn't
want the coins to disappear from the
board because then black is doing very
well actually long term if anyone black
is better because black has a very nice
Bishop coming out to a diagonal White's
Bishop tends to be the worst minor a
piece on the board so yeah it looks very
natural I'm slightly surprised Magnus is
hesitating and delaying this queen move
he does go for it however after a bit of
a think and we might well see the
players race down that variation Magnus
doesn't need to rush by retreating his
Queen uh he could also for example bring
out his Knight to a very nice Square on
F5 this is quite thematic as well the
dream home for Black's night you can
make an argument for bringing the other
night out very flexible this black very
solid but yeah Ivanka what do you think
you mentioned that this isn't what you
recommend or this isn't part of your
repertoire uh this exact yeah it is now
after this night move by Prague and you
can see Magnus has gone for the most
thematic approach which is developed
than uh the Knight to the F5 Square this
is the perfect square for such a knight
in the caracon and he offers a trade of
Queens again so far so good Magnus is
doing all the right things and he's
breaking out now he's challenging
White's Pawn Santa and this as a Cara
player gives me great joy because when
you do this it's either good as in
really good or it's going to be bad and
here I think it's perfect yeah it looks
like good timing for Magnus just before
white started kicking back the black
pieces for example starting to kick back
the black queen Magnus has broken out
and also this creates Square for the
Black Knight which was previously
occupied by a pawn I think here he's
also very happy if we do see a bunch of
exchanges to even give up his Bishop for
the White Knight in these types of
scenarios White's Bishop still struggles
to get to a decent Square Black's
Knights once this one develops they're
just perfectly placed and yeah if if he
can avoid any direct consequences right
now Magnus
he's survived the opening he's got a
very healthy position as black that's
going to make him happy we did hear in
that video before the game Magnus
summing up the season and talking about
Prague a matchup he's enjoyed a lot this
season and praising Prague saying he's
never fearful when he plays against
Magnus and minuses kind of enjoyed it
but also struggled with Prague just
going at it in every single game is this
prag going at it already yeah Prague
hasn't taken a simple approach against
the karakan there are many ways to play
it safe against this opening but this
isn't necessarily one of them no
certainly not and he does capture the
porn and as David indicated the bishop
captures and he's uh Prague is playing
in aggressive style directly attacking
the queen seizing space so I find that
this type of chess for white is quite
risky but also very ambitious at the
same time why is it risky people could
be asking me and that's primarily to do
with the porn structure and the control
of the half open lines if black were to
get safely developed and even into an
end game then they would have all the
the trumps in this position primarily
because they have a Target to attack the
E5 pawn and also a half open C line for
a rook to start exerting pressure yeah
long term black is doing great but the
short-term factors could maybe involve
the black king struggling to find safety
uh black skin if it does Castle on the
usual side the king side you notice the
black H Pawn is maybe not ideally placed
and you might even see black actually
leave the king in the Santa and the king
is is quite fickle creature in the in
this particular variation of the caracon
it goes where it's safest it doesn't
commit itself too early yeah one of my
favorite games that I played in the
caracon as black was when I castled on
move 37 as black
queen side David yeah I think my
opponent uh famous commentator Yonder
Victor Hammer he was he nearly jumped
out of his chair when I castled queen
side he forgot it was still legal but uh
yeah so often here I mean that just kind
of illustrates the fact that Black's
King doesn't necessarily need to make a
decision as long as the center is
blocked with pawns yeah and I think as
soon as Prague starts to hint at an
attack then we'll see Magnus kind of
declare his intentions with the black
king and uh whilst Prague is thinking
it's the perfect time to introduce our
puzzle of the day we have another
fantastic puzzle for you guys at home to
solve now this one is a real
mind-boggling one I think David
described it to me as one of the hardest
mate in twos ever it is white to play
and it was actually composed by Charles
Alexander gilberg and uh get this you're
going to be so impressed in
1877. so it's a pretty old pretty
historic legendary puzzle and uh you
guys at home this one's for you yeah
tweet ask your answer using the hashtag
chess Champs and when you solve it you
will enjoy the feeling of solving one of
the most beautiful made in twos ever
yeah that's what David said the most
beautiful mate into he's ever seen he
brought it to the studio today it's
super difficult take a picture of it and
enjoy it today work on it with your
friends and family send us a picture of
how you're working on the puzzle and let
us know if you can do it or if you're
struggling with it
yep uh you have to be really creative
with this one I won't give too many hits
but I think outside the box and again
process of elimination look at all the
checks first look at all the captures
first look at all the direct attempts
but uh the real answer is very hidden so
good luck to everyone out there trying
to solve it and try not to use a
computer yeah we will know because uh
it's a very human uh kind of way to
appreciate the answer to this puzzle
definitely meanwhile Magnus just
centralizes the black Rook
also very sensible we could see a
puzzle-like finish to this game
potentially if Prague can't build up
some attack okay I kind of vision this
now because Chris
and closer I kind of want to bring this
puzzle home for Christmas and just you
know sit by the fireplace and put it up
on an actual chessboard and sit there
and work on it yeah for hours and hours
it will be you will have to use some
brain power on this one and it's going
to be fine when you guys tweet the
answer today I will have forgotten when
I get home for Christmas and we'll start
on scratch working on this yeah no
problem no I mean I mean that actually
happens to all of us Kaya I mean today I
also brought in a puzzle just to show
David and also the crew and this one up
is my favorite puzzle ever and I still
had kind of more or less forgotten the
answer like and then I was like figuring
out I was like yes yes still got it yeah
I mean but I mean try to solve it
yourself I have to say because there is
nothing better than that Eureka moment
when you've figured out a puzzle it's
like you're a detective solving a crime
and you're like
got it I know who did it and I will say
about this puzzle the second move is
memorable you'll never ever forget the
answer once you spot the second move
yeah so uh yeah try your best to solve
it at home we do have a couple of moves
on the board is anything uh changing at
all the bar is very much uh
still in the middle almost yeah
essentially Magnus has
committed he's said I'm not going to
Castle queenside he's moved his Rook
across and that black Rook was attacked
by White's Bishop White's Bishop now
does look like a pretty decent piece
covering some key squares but
essentially the status quo has been
maintained the center is still closed
and we'll see the game enter a
maneuvering phase in the next few times
okay so that means we have time to bring
up another chess game a very special
tweet came out earlier today it's uh I
actually got a message it's a tweet that
has already gotten for 14.5 million
likes on Cristiano Ronaldo's Twitter
page it's this picture of Lionel Messi
and Cristiano Ronaldo playing a chess
game on top of a Louis Vuitton suitcase
a checkered suitcase how cool of a
picture is that and of course the moment
we saw this we thought wait what kind of
a game are they playing are they playing
an actual chess game and David you took
a look at this what do you think yes it
is an actual game it's taken from a real
life game between the two greatest chess
players in the world these are the two
greatest footballers uh playing right
now for sure this is a game between
Magnus Carlson and Hikaru Nakamura from
norwichs 2017. we had to zoom in we had
to work out which pieces were and which
squares
um it's slightly confusing the
dimensions but this was from a real game
and it looks like it's black to play in
the position so it's Messi's move uh
Messi is black Ronaldo is white in this
position and as we saw in that game
between Carson and Nakamura the Messi
Ronaldo of chess it did end up in a draw
so here white has an extra Bishop white
would be winning the game if it's his
move if it's white to play the Queen
will step forward uh hitting the black
king but uh the game did end with a draw
the black queen gave a came across gave
a check the black queen stepped back and
the checks continued no way to escape
for petrol check so it's very fitting
between Ronaldo and Messi the two
greatest players in the world uh
greatest footballers it was a draw and
how cool that when they did this photo
shoot
they found an actual chess game and they
decided to to make it a chess game
between
Magnus and Hikaru whose idea do you
think it was Ronaldo maybe he's met
Magnus several times quite possibly uh I
remember Magnus uh kicking off at some
Real Madrid matches when Ronaldo was
there maybe that was an inside joke
between them maybe they just thought oh
we're the two greatest footballers of
our time who are the two greatest chess
players most famous chess players of the
time I think that would be Magnus and
Hikaru I'm not sure who's who would
Magnus B Ronaldo would Hikaru be Ronaldo
wait so who was the white and that the
Magnus Hikaru game
I think magnus's I think Magnus was
white
uh we will have to get that confirmed
but Magnus was white yeah Ronaldo Magnus
Messi Nakamura I bet Cristiano Ronaldo
brought this game and said he wanted to
be white and be Magnus Carlsen
quite possible and uh yeah maybe in
future years they'll reenact a game
between Magnus and Prague two of the
greatest players of this generation
[Music]
that is so seriously cool and I love the
kind of iconic Louis Vuitton
checkerboard style so it's perfect
Fusion football stars chess
baton yeah golden three beautiful
meanwhile a long think now from Magnus
Carlson Prague has played a very
mysterious move the white Rook coming
across it's lining up against the black
queen buds it's not 100 clear what the
plan is for Prague I think he's just
saying to Magnus you can't improve your
position the black king is a bit
stranded doesn't really want to commit
and Castle yet
so uh yeah it's definitely the ball in
magnus's court it
s thing because the players are
following two games from my database
so this has all been seen before
whoops that was my phone I'm sorry
everyone you know this was has happened
to me during commentary as well
you know in the chess game that would be
a loss
and it's also part of the chess
nightmare you know I I always have like
I'm I'm turning up to a chest ornament
I'm getting ready to play my first game
and in this nightmare I have like an
iPad I have three phones I have my
confused with me why I have all these
devices I don't know and I cannot switch
them off and uh but I was just gonna say
about this particular position is that
White's uh Rook move is actually
signifying an intent to expand even
further on the left side of the board to
pick up the B Pawn move it two squares
forward attack the queen and just just
make Black's life very uncomfortable
there on the left and also the right
because remember white is just trying to
swarm the position just trying to take
as much space as possible and suffocate
black
yeah and uh Magnus will feel that
suffocating effect if he can't find any
productive moves right now
I really worry for the norwegian's
position the evaluation Bar says black
is fine uh it's not a significant
Advantage for white but it's just about
plans and white does have a clear plan
as Ivanka mentioned or white wants to
push his people next move what does
Magnus do in the meantime
it's a bit of a mystery to me and we can
just show that just to illustrate it on
the board
to make it clear white wants to push his
Pawn forward that's why he shifted his
Rook across just to defend the C Pawn
for example if black just Waits I'm not
sure how Moose's Rook for example then
white people could step forward kicking
back the black queen and the black queen
doesn't have too many squares to be
honest uh she has to be careful where
she steps and white now would have an
option to push this Pawn forward kicking
the Knight away maybe even push this
Pawn forward hitting the queen at some
point and uh the advance continues
White's pawns are taking so much space
and the reason why Magnus is stuck is
because castling here does feel wrong if
black castles then at some point white
will move his Knight away I'm not sure
whether he does that now or on the next
few moves but uh this is the big Target
sometimes advancing Pawns in front of
your king can have long-term
consequences and this is a very severe
consequence you can't really defend it
for example pushing your Pawn forward
because suddenly White's Bishop enters
in the dark squares and there are too
many holes in front of the black king
white will later utilize these with a
mating threat mating attack yeah and uh
I don't like castling at all and
primarily also because the black queen
is far divorced from parking
it's kind of all if your king is under
Fire you always warn your queen to be
close to the king if she's divorced and
moved far further away then this is bad
news moved on in life this queen Queens
are great pieces but they're also you
know fantastic attackers the house are
excellent Defenders and when your your
king is going to withstand some heavy
Onslaught you really need your queen
there and wow after almost six minutes
I thought that Magnus would actually
slow down the play and go backwards with
the queen just in anticipation of
White's porn move but instead he just
accelerates everything wow and this is
important sacrifice if this Pawn is
captured by Prague then there's a double
attack on the black queen The Black
Queen has to run now she's hit by the
rook and by the pawn I guess you'll step
back Magnus is arguing that suddenly the
center's blocked in a different way yes
he's a pawn down but this Pawn isn't
going to survive long term the two Black
Knight to eyeing It Up The Rook is
eyeing it up and he will regain it in
favorable circumstances later the big
question for me is whether Prague can
continue his attack this is exactly what
you mentioned uh Ivanka this is what he
wanted to do anyway and now the black
queen would have to move I'm not sure
where she runs to I guess she wants to
evacuate the C file and again could for
example step forward and this one gets
really complicated it feels like black
is living on the edge maybe you can take
a pawn to counter-attack against the
White Queen suddenly the queen has hit
the Black Knight is hit and it gets
complicated calculation is required
that's why Prague suddenly has his head
in his hands he's realizing that Magnus
is playing with fire and he will want to
find a way to take advantage thinking
for one minute now so we're gonna head
to San Francisco it's a big day there
Magnus can decide the tour finals in a
big match against uh Prague and Tanya
what's happening in and around where the
players are sitting in the arena
God we've got Adisa here with us who's
the man behind running the hip-hop Chess
Federation as well as 64 blocks that
brings together Jiu Jitsu and chess I
know mind-blowing an easy way to tell us
how he does it all Arisa it's amazing to
have you here with us thank you so much
for joining I'm just happy you're here
in the bay and you came at a perfect
time the weather's great Champions are
great I'm happy to be here thank you so
much and it's amazing to have the event
happening in San Francisco in the Bay
Area what's it like to have all these
chess players around here I'm only used
to seeing this in St Louis so I'm super
happy because the weather's better and
so is the food you know what I'm saying
so I'm happy it's it's exciting I was
amazed to hear the kind of stuff that
you're doing here and I really want to
ask you tell us I want to start with the
hip-hop Chess Federation
come into your head what happened is I
was working with some kids in juvenile
hall I asked them if they played chess
and like 90 percent of the kids play
chess but they made poor decisions as
human beings Mike how can so many kids
that play chess end up in juvenile hall
so I started working on a program to use
the lyrics from rap music because rap
music actually celebrates chess more
than any other form of music to kind of
lure them into playing the game and it
worked really well I ended up bringing
in you know Wu-Tang members like Rizza
and Giza and a bunch of other high-end
uh high-profile rappers to help and we
did work in in St Louis in 2014
um living like kings I was I was the
guest curator at the World Chess Hall of
Fame and that was the second biggest
opening day uh that they've ever had
except for like Bobby Fischer you know
what I mean so we beat Bobby Fisher's uh
exhibit which is unbelievable but that's
only because chess is so I mean chess
and Hip-Hop are so loved right by young
people
that's incredible and I want to ask you
did you see a big draw that was with the
kids when they saw Hip-Hop come along
with us well yeah I did because you know
once you tell them they look you know
Rizza and Giza from Wu-Tang play Will
Smith is a player 50 Cent as a player
right it doesn't mean that they're high
level players but that they're thinking
about structure about risk about you
know what I mean about coming back from
loss and so these are the things that we
say if you can do that on the board you
can do it in your life
you mentioned that that's one genre of
music that really celebrates chess in a
big way do you have a favorite bar I do
well I have uh the song weak spot by
Wu-Tang Clan one of my homies Giza he
says I stay on 64 squares while
patrolling the center treading space for
material the time zone I enter it's a
calculated movement from push pieces
Advanced development once the pawn
reaches the eighth rank now heavily
armed with a tank my opponent's base is
threatened soldiers cut with Shanks this
is the kind of stuff that very much
inside the space of hip-hop but you're
not always going to see it in the pop
artist so you know you gotta you gotta
dig for it but it's absolutely there has
it always amazed you the kind of
analogies that come out of the
chessboard yeah I mean it's it's there
you know these analogies are as infinite
as the moves in the game itself and
that's why it's always enriching and
that's why you guys are here now because
right like the game is still super
relevant not just uh in the hood but
around the world
now you started with the hip-hop Chess
Federation and then you moved on to
combine Jiu Jitsu one of the fastest
growing martial art forms along with
chess
tell us about that how did that happen
so I'm a black belt and Brazilian Jiu
Jitsu and I teach it and I started
seeing correlations between chess
methodologies and Jiu Jitsu
methodologies and I was like you know
America needs more and young people need
more physical and mental balance right
so they work hard on Jiu Jitsu they work
hard on the chessboard the meditation
centers them to improve both and the
results have been fantastic
and what have you noticed the
similarities between these two because
the first thought is wait how does chess
fit in Wichita well chess uh is very
strategic and Jiu Jitsu is very
strategic as a martial art
um they're they're like if two people
start fighting there's a measured way or
if one grabs the other there's a
response if he knows it if they do that
response there are three variant
responses and these think it's just like
chess so for me chess is Jiu Jitsu for
the mind and Jiu Jitsu is just for the
body
between these themes in chess as well as
the tactics and strategy used to well in
Jiu Jitsu yeah I mean like you know zugz
Wang like using small movements to
prevent advancement uh you know uh like
like moves to like you know what I mean
setting traps yeah yeah exactly you can
set up tracks you can set up uh forked
attacks right so you can go from an arm
lock to a triangle choke to another
thing called an omo Plata it's a
shoulder lock but these things in a jiu
jitsu player's mind they fire off
instantly you know wow I love it uh have
you seen an improvement in one of them
affect performance in the other yeah
absolutely yeah so you can see like
sometimes people can get a chess concept
and apply it on the mat like same day so
traditionally when I was teaching at
zetuna College over here in Berkeley
when I was teaching in like 2017 we do
rounds of Chess and rounds of rolling
back to back also to make you like have
to play chess under a high stress
situation because now you're half out of
breath you know you know you almost got
choked and now you're trying to figure
out how to win the game and then the
bell rings and you go back to the mats
so it's intense
love it and Adisa tell us that the
training in Jiu Jitsu and chess and this
Academy that you run how has that
impacted your students lives outside the
academy well you know when I was doing
hip-hop Chess Federation which I shut
down in 2019 I had seen a lot of that 64
blocks is brand new but we're starting
to roll out in uh Redwood City at a
place called the afro Bushido Academy
you can follow me at real64 blocks on
Instagram at real64 blocks and you can
learn more there in 2023 we're going to
roll out the website and we'll we'll
show everything then wow we are so happy
to have you here with us and before we
let you go the final question who are
you rooting for here at the meltwater
Champions Chester final man you got to
put me on I mean like I love Carlson I
love everybody but like I like to see
his ups and downs and I like to see his
determination that's impressive because
it's easy when you're killing everybody
to just show up and whatever but when
you gotta rethink restructure and and
and refocus to win again that's where I
see the champion you know and so I'm I'm
inspired by him in in his uh in his
consistence returns thank you so much
and there we have it Kaya some inspiring
stuff going on in the Bay Area here with
Adisa follow him on Instagram for more
information and where you can find this
Academy thank you so much for joining so
much and come back to the Bay as soon as
you can everybody come back come back I
need you to stay hang out
that is so cool hip-hop Chess Federation
is that the the next thing you're
getting involved in David it's
definitely on my list and next time I'm
in the bay I know you too who to contact
yeah for chess Jiu Jitsu for everything
yeah how cool all right we had quite a
few moves on the board the bar has been
quite significantly off for Prague now
it's more towards the middle what's
happening in the game yeah and uh just
while uh Tanya and Adisa were talking
Ivanka and I were discussing the
position it feels like Magnus he's
managed to get over the worst but he had
to walk a bit of a tightrope to get here
and just to refresh just to show the
moves that we uh missed there a moment
ago white did indeed stop pushing pawns
forward we mentioned the B4 B5 throwing
the pawns forward gaining time against
the black pieces that was about to
happen it did indeed happen and this was
a critical moment because uh maybe the
most natural moves here the Knight is uh
kind of attacked the most natural move
here would be to either jump into the
center or to jump to the side of the
board but these would have been decisive
mistakes for example jumping into the
center now after a trade of knights
white doesn't necessarily need to get
greedy and take this Pawn back instead
white could step either one square
forward or one square to the side and
the whole idea now is that you cut
across this diagonal Black's King cannot
Castle through Trek and therefore is
stranded for the rest of the game the
king is an easy target now uh White will
try and regain this pawn and try to
break through to the back rank this
would have been just too scary for black
too dangerous and therefore Magnus found
a really important Retreat he stepped
his Knight back guarding that diagonal
so now the queen is stepping forward for
example wouldn't cut across black could
still safely Castle the king and uh as
we saw in the game it that meant that
Prague had nothing better than Rook
takes pawn and magnus's King finally
does find safety better late than never
it castled or moved 22. it's very late
in chess and uh now that he has castled
he can look forward to the future with
confidence okay white stepping back with
his queen I'm expecting Magnus at some
point to bring the Knight into the game
sitting behind Prager in San Francisco
is Wesley so today fighting a very
important match against Jan Christoph
Duda they both know that if Magnus loses
today they have chances to win the Tour
finals both Wesley so and Young Chris of
Judah and here in game one do the with
the white pieces the bar has been up for
Wesley so almost from the start actually
do you think Wesley is winning that game
one yeah I wouldn't necessarily
necessarily say winning but he's doing
very well and you can tell on dude's
face he doesn't look too happy about his
position normally when Dude is confident
we see the lean back the smile from the
Polish fighter there but uh yeah
difficult starts and that continues a a
run now of uh kind of maybe substandard
subpar play from Duda we saw yesterday
just the angry kind of the anger at
himself the frustration uh blundering a
few times losing a few games to Prague
letting it slip in the Armageddon when
Prague had only 25 seconds left
he could have prolonged that game maybe
one on the clock but uh yeah and dude it
feels like things are going against him
and sometimes that's hard to turn that
Trend in chess yeah yeah and uh there we
see the knights spring forward to the
Santa attacking the rook and The Rook
Julie moves to the fourth row so Prague
is potentially getting ready to switch
over to the right side if needed and
attack the black king so uh thinking
back to duda's reaction yesterday that
was so natural I have to say how many of
us have reacted in exactly the same way
using the exact same swear words ah it
was so human actually and I'm really
glad that Duda revealed that actually
that side to him because often
especially even over the board chess
everyone is kind of really
stoic and you don't see that reaction
unless it's private and here it was raw
just Fury yeah that's the difference
right between over the board chests and
online chess often there isn't a camera
in your face but players do get more
emotional they're not afraid to express
themselves but I think you'll write your
bank at the board even if I'm furious
even if I want to throw the pieces even
if I want to punch the wall you know you
have to suppress it and that's why this
tour's been so refreshing we see the
players showing their passion all of
these guys they want to win more than
anything else in the world they don't
care about anything other than that full
point the Victory and uh Duda really
displaying his emotions yesterday
meanwhile Magnus offering to exchange
Rooks what do you think Ivanka you're
the caricon expert in the house if all
the major Pieces come off the board if
the Rooks and queens disappear who would
you prefer that I would prefer
it's equal really
I mean I want to say in principle I
prefer black but uh no I mean I have to
be honest I think black has a tremendous
night on D5 also a fantastic night on F5
they're on outpost they can't really be
chased away but I'm not going to take
away the fact that white also has great
pieces and control of the open lines so
it's a very very balanced game at the
minute and I don't see it going too
wrong for either side yeah so you think
even though Magnus is down under three
minutes it's within controllable margins
here yeah for black yeah it's just those
two black knights they're So Glorious
they hold everything together yeah yeah
I mean I I mean that I don't think why
black is in any trouble I mean the only
thing I would say that black should be a
slightly careful careful of is uh the
king you must always watch out for the
king because White's pieces are primed
and ready to add the to a right time to
switch over and start tacking the one
week's book in the position which is the
H5 Pawn if you attack that P that pawn
and black isn't ready then you're
looking at some trouble yeah I I
completely agree it's this one the only
weakness in the in the game that's why I
love Black's last move so much swing The
Rook across just to distract white to
try and trade off pieces if black had
been too slow for example maybe pushing
this Pawn forward then just as an
example after an exchange of Pawns white
could already be tempted to switch
attention and uh even throw a pawn
forward I'm not sure you want to do this
immediately it's very risky but the
white Rook would be able to swing across
and there might be some threats against
the black king but this was not allowed
by Magnus he offered this exchange of
Rooks tying white down here and yes
White's retreated white tonight wants to
aim into some juicier squares
potentially but Magnus has finally
activated his last piece and I think
that's a great sign the evaluation bar
agrees suddenly the position is turning
in Black's favor this black Rook maybe
shouldn't have been allowed into the
game and after a trade suddenly black is
the one Conquering the open file
I agree with you that I mean Prague has
been very like one track is the same
with a one-track mind he just wants to
attack on the right side but you have to
be so careful in these type of positions
not to allow black to overrun in the
center and you know look how passive he
is he's attacking on the back row I mean
lacks Rook perfectly placed the queen is
now going to come in I mean there's no
reason for black to even think about
defending that pawn I mean you can
defend it of course but
why should you yeah I think you called
it with this Quinn move that Magnus has
just chosen the black queen suddenly is
active tying white down to some pieces
over here uh some pawns on the left side
if White NOW does get greedy and grab
this pawn it feels like there should be
consequences
um I don't see it immediately but
White's attack still needs time to build
up Black's Rook could start coming in
for example
um this does look a bit scary for white
to deal with some tension along the
second rank yes Knight just temporarily
defended by White's Bishop but finally
black would be able to start trying to
capture it
I mean you also have to worry about this
Knight coming in at some point uh even
black just got ingredient grabbing some
Pawns as long as there's no Checkmate
against the black king then uh Magnus
should be happy enough and we're going
to see this critical variation this is
the acid test of what Magnus here is
doing and okay he does take the spawn so
both Queens have got greedy Black's
Queen is far divorced as you coined uh
from its king so maybe that's one
worrying sign for black but white is
only attacking with a queen right now
the bishop doesn't really do anything uh
White's Bishop is hitting thin air it
has to be joined by the Knight
we are going to see Prague here go all
in it's as if he's thrown all of his
chips into the center he's saying I'm
going for checkmate I'm going for
something against the black king but the
two black knights will act as Defenders
and Magnus is calling the bluff he's
saying nope I don't care I'm just gonna
take all the Pawns
wow thank you I mean the evaluation bar
seems to say black is just almost
winning now
does that mean that Prague has just got
nothing maybe he's just hoping for
tricks well to a computer okay cold
bloodedly works it all out uh Prague has
definitely got nothing but to a human
this does look very scary so I mean
First Reactions would be like first
going forward can some peace come to the
F6 square and sacrifice itself you know
to open up lines again against the black
king another option is just to retreat
the bishop just to make way for the
Knight to jump to G5 sadly there's just
no way in for the white Rook
and finally my last attempt at attacking
would be to push my Jeep on forward and
dislodged that night on F5 yeah and this
is a funny trick that Magnus has
obviously if I think if the pawn steps
forward he doesn't need to move his
Knight he can trap the White Queen on
the edge of the board and uh that would
be a sad end to the game for Prague but
this is the type of thing that can
happen if you get over excited and if
you try to attack when you're not fully
ready so Prague has to be a bit careful
here I agree um he wants to push this
Pawn maybe he wants to get his Knight
into the game he can't get his rook in
one move that comes to my mind would be
maybe moving the bishop up with gain of
tempo to the black rook and uh and then
maybe trying to jump in with the white
knight but no Prague does indeed just
Shuffle his Rook across he moves his
Rook to D1 but what is that doing is he
getting ready to sacrifice his Rook
potentially yeah it has to be I mean
there's otherwise it's just a very
mysterious Rook move so Rook takes
Knight potentially threatens with the
idea of them following it through with
some more sacrifices for example if
white gut gets given time to take this
Knight off the board suddenly white can
jump in with a check and here it's very
unclear whether black is able to jump
and stop any checkmates in time now this
is prague's idea to play Rook takes
Knight removing a Defender taking this
piece off the board but Magnus does have
one move here he needs to potentially
defend against that threat or
counter-attack somehow
and black is winning black has two uh
Point Advantage according to the
computer but you need to be careful the
margin for error is Tiny yeah and I just
wanted to highlight one other threat
that white has potentially is to
actually just come in with a knight to
F6 immediately yeah jump in anyway for
example if the pawn captures then uh
yeah as soon as the Black Knight moves
for example if it steps back to capture
this bishop then white does have ideas
at some point of bringing the rook in
with a devastating background checkmate
so Prague yeah he's not out of resources
yet maybe we can see the top moves the
top suggestions from stockfish how
narrow is magnus's path to defend this
position he's a pawn up as black but how
many moves does he have to survive
okay it says that black is got a
decisive Advantage if he finds two moves
and they both attack this white knight
in the center of the board this is a
target it's undefended so you can attack
it with the black Rook or you can attack
it with the black queen this is not 100
easy neither of those moves are maybe
the ones that are first on the radar
they're not
clear candidate moves the third choice
for the computer you got that one I mean
that's so Random that's just to add to
absolutely eager
threats so uh oh and he doesn't find any
of the top three moves Magnus does that
give prag a winning move nope it's just
level again and it's back in the balance
it's all about whether Pride can break
through with a sacrifice if he can't
then he'll have to look for other
avenues maybe he'll now sidestep his
Rook to try and get in on the open C
file he's still very tense from a human
point of view practical point of view
it's looking scary I think white is
going to be very happy here uh Prague
with an extra minute on the clock he's
the one attacking it's always easier to
attack with less time
and uh yeah let's go back to the players
is Magnus sweating is he showing any
signs of nerves
it always seems to be this kind of
narrative between the two it's always
prag attacking always Magnus reacting
it's very rarely like that in any of
magnus's games against any other
opponent
it's incredibly impressive from the
young Indian player
we thought just a few moves ago he was
running out of steam he was running out
of ideas but there he goes he drops back
the queen uh stockfish did confirm a few
moments ago that this was one of White's
best moves lining up the queen with the
black king some tricks there potentially
yeah and uh Magnus will now be
considering what Prague is threatening
and that's why he runs away with the
King because white was potentially
threatening to advance the H board maybe
come in to F6 with a peace sacrifice and
Magnus desperately trying to clarify the
situation he's keeping his King in
safety and at the same time oh and we
see Prague Retreat return the queen to
where she came from and so does the king
so will we see a draw by threefold
repetition
it's possible this is the second time
we've seen this position now if Craig
steps back with the White Queen he's
asking Magnus that question do you want
a draw and they they can't offer drawers
or they won't offer drawers they'll just
uh I mean it's a battle of Mind Games
now
would you take the draw here if you were
Prague would you play on would you keep
risking to try and break through and
Checkmate no I the problem is that if I
were Prague I'm playing against Magnus
Carlson so I would take the draw
I can't handle the tension and and well
we're gonna see whether Magnus is
feeling ambitious and wants to play on
or is he satisfied with draw magnets
down at around 30 seconds though it
would be so brief to take a risk now and
not repeat the position Black's King
does look like it's a Target but Magnus
is the one to reject the draw reject the
repetition he offers a trade of Rook
stepping back Black's Knight will he
live to regret that decision though
well it's looking like it's going to be
a great round for the players with the
black pieces at least in the other three
matches bar all the way over to Wesley
Southside to our guysi side and to
mamadiar outside question is can Magnus
Carlsen also win with the black pieces
listening to you guys I guess anything
can happen in this game yeah definitely
as long as the Queens stay on the board
Prague has great attacking chances black
is one point up though so if the Queens
disappear those two black pawns will win
the game and prague's giving up a piece
he's trucked his Bishop in the heart of
Black's position this is a peace
sacrifice because now after a rook trade
there's no more pin black can actually
that can maybe grab this bishop you have
to calculate this very carefully
can you just call pranks Bluff and take
this white Bishop off the board computer
seems to think black is winning
is Magnus reacting to this let's uh see
Magnus as well yeah we need to watch
both players here because the nerves
will be juggling for both of them he
doesn't bite the bullet he doesn't take
White's bishop and I think that was a
good decision if you had taken White's
Bishop the White Queen would have come
to the top of the board delivered a
nasty check but look at this black
Retreat blocking the white Queen's entry
points it's suddenly Prague he's really
gone all in again 10 seconds
and I think the thing is he's burnt his
bridges yeah that night Retreat is such
a good
move and if that Bishop moves well
suddenly the E5 Pawn Falls and Magnus is
completely winning and uh the queen
slides over one square but Magnus he's
just forcing an in-game yeah he's
closing the door every time White's
Queen tries to get in behind the black
pieces Magnus shuts down either with his
queen or with his Knights black only has
good defensive pieces left and finally
he does get greedy he does seize the
moment to take White's Bishop so right
now black is a whole night ahead but
will the black king survive feels like
Black's King should have enough
Defenders around it those two black
knights are just great pieces but some
dangerous tracks you You Can't Take Your
Eye Off the Ball 15 seconds for Magnus
now
White Queen is threatening to check from
the front maybe occasionally she can try
and jump in along the diagonal and check
from behind but Magnus he needs to move
how does he keep his King safe he keeps
it he tries to run forward out into the
open he's going to keep advancing down
the board and it's counter-intuitive but
it looks safe enough for now there's no
checks with the White Queen White Knight
can give a check however maybe that's
what we'll see Prague do yeah and I'm
I'm actually predicting that that Knight
Will retreat at the right time to age
six and this is why Prague just moved
his Queen one square to the side you
know she's threatening to give a check
on age five or a knight is going to jump
in and oh Magnus using the whole board
just to defend his King look how the
queen gave a check and she returned all
the way back such classy move yep really
really nice use of geometry there using
all the angles suddenly the queen and
king they're back together they've
reunited and that does spell maybe the
end for pregnantanda he gives a check
with his Knight now Black's King has to
March into the eye line of the White
Queen this is with this uh look this was
the only safe Square sorry it's so
exciting right now but Prague the
problem is you can give a discover check
but Black's Queen will block and you're
just a night down no more compensation
you have to trade the queens and that
will spell the end yeah I love this
beautiful romantic story Ivanka saying
earlier in the game that the queen and
king had the divorced and now David's
saying they're reunited back to together
again and that's going to win the game
for Magnus it is going to win the game
for the Magnus and still there's a
margin to go wrong especially with the
black king so open but okay he has some
great pieces surrounding his King those
Knights they're fantastic Defenders I'm
fully expecting Magnus to actually
capture the Knight Queen takes and step
back with the queen and there we go
it is going to be game over there's just
really no way that the White Queen can
fight all alone against Black's Army I
mean just take a look at those two pawns
there the A and the B pawns they're just
gonna promote yeah those two black porns
are gonna start running sooner rather
than later and white pawns they look
pretty good but the problem is as soon
as you start advancing them you weaken
the white king the white king is on the
wrong side of the board you have to try
this there's simply nothing else for
Prague but uh the queen of night
together for black
I'm just gonna defend everything they're
gonna hold everything if black can force
a queen trade that's game over those two
black pawns will decide that's what
Magnus is trying to do planting his
Knight in the center unless there's some
miraculous Perpetual check now from
pregnantanda then he can essentially
resign but look at this Black's King yet
again hides on the side of the board and
no more tracks any Queen track will just
result in a queen trade and uh yeah
running out of any positive ideas here
now for white seven seconds five seconds
the clock is ticking for Prague and he
Retreats the king I mean there's really
nothing for it he just has to push his
pawns forward and hope for the best and
here comes Alice she's wandering down
the board
we saw Prague shake his head he knows
that he's relying on a huge blunder now
also the clock times are against him
Magnus was down at a few seconds when he
was defending for his life but he's
built up a huge time Advantage almost at
the one minute Mark now and again just
centralizing his Queen he's trying to
say yes the White Queen can go and
capture Black's pawns but then the white
pawns would fall
yeah any any defensive idea here would
involve weakening the white king even
further pregnant under five seconds he
does try and grab a pawn but it's not
going to be enough Black's Queen and
Knight are gonna team up now maybe even
deliver some checkmating threats
yeah I mean the first move to calculate
is actually the night coming forward to
the F4 square and some deadly check
mating ideas on the boards and uh take a
look at the black king it can do some
running of its own as well so everything
is working in magnus's favor he's got a
safe place to hide the king queen and
Knight perfect attacking Duo and uh he's
following the principles putting the
queen in the center she's controlling as
many squares as possible this is such a
good technique and Prague just 10
seconds left on the clock and his
position is dire and in the background
we see Wesley so he has just won the
first game today against Jan Crist of
Duda that means hopes for Wesley so of
winning the tour finals
if Magnus loses the match today right
now that's not looking good for Wesley
Magnus about to win yeah and this is the
danger when you don't attack correctly
and when the attack Fizzles out you
might just be material down and here we
do see as Ivanka advocated Black's King
he's going to start marching forward why
not white is attacking with only a queen
the safest way to avoid the checks is to
hide behind the white pawns to hide
behind your own pieces potentially and
here black can just munch on that white
H Pawn very safely and the checks will
start to dry up only one move that
Magnus must not play he must not step
forward with his King to the G4 square
if he does that he's gonna lose he's
going to get checkmated but Magnus he's
too clever he just centralizes the queen
and uh yeah that's it we have a result
Magnus has won the first game with the
black pieces taking the lead here minus
Carlson
impressive stuff you will have the white
pieces in 11 minutes